Conrad came in and I think he has any
idea how handsome he is very handsome
you are you hiding it under all is yeah
very handsome
he's a construction worker he wants to
own his own construction company we
could get captaincy de gens thing yeah
once we clean you up there was some wily
just up serious hand rolled back to the
pound a towel my intuition I think when
I first saw him was like oh we're gonna
get rid of the beard we're gonna cut his
hair short and you're like I know keep
that keep that like saltiness you know
keep that math skill in this but I think
about what he was wearing a he was
wearing this kind of like printed
sweatshirt and baggy sweatpants and he
was wearing sneakers I mean without my
personal size like chaos we wanted to
keep all these guys person how things
would be one change the problems were to
keep who they are but just you know help
them find the best version of themselves
so we wanted to keep him casual in a way
but just really upgrade him so he looks
like the guy who really owns the company
by putting him in this beautiful you
know top coat and turtleneck and pants
you're not trying to take him out of his
element you know in the vernacular of
his world but it obviously a very luxe
version Conrad was a great pleasure
because once we had addressed I think he
felt very very proud and he really
projected into the camera he was so easy
to photograph yes I think I am good
model today Don Paulus was really
professional it's a pleasure work with
him I think men in our culture rarely
get kind of
that we paid to all of these guys during
this process women are very used to
having men say to them wow you look so
great you look beautiful
I don't think most women say that to men
very much so if you're a woman and
you're watching this say something nice
about the guy in your life